well this is one of the most incredible
things about Berg I not 100 sure but I
think he is the only cult leader who has
ever managed to do that to successfully
maintain such a high level of control
yeah over you know 10 to 15 000 people
without them ever meeting him without
them ever being in his presence he was
that charismatic through his words and
he had that level of control through his
leadership team
so he he was he lived in hiding for
the majority of his life yeah because
when we've been talking so far I
imagined that it was him moving to
Thailand and saying right we're moving
here now setting it up then him no no we
were everywhere across the globe even in
the west which was evil he still
maintained smaller communes there we
were absolutely in every continent